I think I'm going to answer where do you
fall short in these 12 rules?
Is it a cost constant adjustment?
You know what?
I wrote these rules.
What you mean?
Why did I write these rules?
Well,
you know,
and especially when I said,
well,
you should try to improve yourself
instead of trying to set the world
straight or instead of worrying about
what other people are doing wrong,
you might say,
well that's a hell of a thing for
someone to say,
you just wrote a book called 12 rules
for lights.
It's like,
no,
but the thing is is that I wasn't just
writing that.
I was reading that for me as much as for
anyone else and I mean that's.
I really mean that sincerely.
You know,
I had an opportunity to spend somewhere
around five years meditating on how you
should conduct yourself so that your
life is what it could be.
And like I'm in the group of people that
I'm advising you.
You know what I mean?
It's like all of these things are very
difficult to stand up straight to
remember that and to treat yourself like
you're someone worthwhile and to make
friends with people who are good for you
and to tell the truth or at least not to
lie.
I mean these are all ideals,
right,
and especially taken as a whole.
They constituted a kind of ideal and you
never.
You never.
You never attained the ideal,
the eye,
and not only that,
it recedes as you approach it,
right?
Because you straighten yourself out and
you think,
well,
I've got it now and you think,
no,
wait a minute.
There's more to gold.
There's still more to go,
and then you get that much farther along
the line you think,
cool,
yeah,
I thought this was the end of the road.
It's like,
no,
there's plenty of imperfections left to
iron out,
and so it is a constant adjustment and.
But there's something about that that's
also positive because you might say that
it's not so much that there isn't such a
thing as a good person.
It's that our idea of what constitutes
good isn't right,
because a good person is someone who's
trying to get better and no matter how
good you are,
there's better that you can get,
but the real goodness is in the attempt,
right?
It's in.
It's in the process too.
To use somewhat of a Cliche,
you know,
there's this,
oh,
and I'll close with this,
and it's a good way to close.
You know,
and this is a psychological observation.
The,
the central figure of Western culture is
Christ.
And we can look at that psychologically
because Christ is the dying and
resurrected hero.
And what does that mean psychologically?
Well,
it means that
you've learned things painfully,
and when you learn something painfully a
part of you has to die.
That's the pain.
You know,
when a dream is shattered,
for example,
a huge part of you that,
that constituted that dream.
Maybe even the biological substrate of
that June has to be stripped away in and
burned.
And so life is a constant process of
death and rebirth.
And to participate in that fully is to
allow yourself to be redeemed by it.
And so the good is that process of death
and rebirth voluntarily undertaken.
It's like you're not as good as you
could be.
So he let that part of you die.
And if someone comes along and says,
you know,
there's some deadwood here,
man,
it needs to be burned off.
You think,
well,
that stuff's still a bit alive when that
Burns,
it's going to hurt.
It's like,
yeah,
well no kidding.
But maybe the thing that emerges in its
place is something better.
And I think this is the secret of human
beings.
This is what we're like,
you know,
unlike any other creature is that we can
let our old selves die and let our new
selves be bored.
And that's what we should do.
And so where do I fall short in these 12
rules?
Well,
endlessly because.
here's a way of thinking about it until
the entire world is redeemed.
We all fall short.
And that's probably a good place to
stop.
Thanks.